hot's probably the next in line to fight
Strickland for the middleweight title as
of today on October 23rd and going just
based off straight up the data that we
have the video footage of fight footage
that we have of Hamot and going based
off the fight foot we have of Strickland
I would put all my money on Strickland
to beat Hamot in five rounds cuz if if
you look at Hamot right now there's
nothing in his past five fights that
would lead you to assume he's going to
be able to steamroll Strickland that
first round maybe this beginning of the
second round could be a bit of a
challenge for Strickland but if you
don't get that done in that first round
Strickland is the worst match up for
Hamot now you look at his cardio you
look at who uh Strickland has beat
before the way he's beat him the way he
melts dudes down I think his grappling
is underrated and just the tenacity it
is a issue for Hamza man